il est un peu plus de 2 heures du matin
lorsque les cinq engins de chantiers
démarrent leur mission démolir le pont
marcel cachin qui surplombe la route
nationale 10 au niveau de la mairie de
trappes la déconstruction de cet ouvrage
datant de 1970 va durer toute la nuit
c'est déjà une partie de la mémoire des
trappes qui part mais elle est simple as
i am un veinures presque radieux de
laver des trappes parce que là il va
s'agir bien sûr de recoudre la ville de
trappes et qui a été rompu par la
nationale 10 et des prix sa création est
holla au bar etc outre complètement
l'avis des trappes caron personnes ont
été mobilisées sur ce chantier mené dans
la nuit du 17 au 18 août par la
direction des routes d'île de france
première étape emblématique d'une
opération qui l'est tout autant
l'enfouissement de la nationale 10 à
trappes cette requalification doit
rétablir la continuité urbaine entre le
nord et le sud de la ville coupée par la
kz et moments clés parce que bien sûr le
but de cette première phase c'était
démolir cet ouvrage qui en fait nous
empêche d'aller creuser la rn10 pour
faire l'opération
les intrus du monde des molières que
pont derrière pouvoir offrir les rênes
lice le lendemain le tablier du pont a
complètement disparu les ouvriers sont à
pied d'oeuvre pour le rétablissement de
la circulation prévue maximum au jeudi
19 août matin le chantier va désormais
se poursuivre jusqu'en octobre avant de
nouvelles étapes dans la foulée sera
attaqué le deuxième gros chantier de
l'opération qui est la transformation du
carrefour entre la rn 10 et la rd 912
alors c'est le carrefour qui fait
l'entraîneur de trappes qui va être
transformé en un grand giratoire avec un
passage souterrain en dessous du
giratoire ça permettra en fait de
fluidifier la circulation surface depuis
le 23 juillet les automobilistes peuvent
emprunter un ouvrage provisoire à
proximité directe de l'expo marcel
cachin pour franchir la route nationale
l'opération d'enfouissement de la rn10
doit durer jusqu'en 2026 coût total 95
millions d'euros